hey good afternoon Seattle aren't
Stephanie Zhang and I am data scientist
at AppNexus I'm Salvatore and Chara I'm
an optimization engineer at at Maxis and
today we're going to be talking to you
about a redesigned algorithm on our
platform so it's 347 right now on a
Saturday afternoon so if you're here you
must really love online advertising or
your boss is sitting next to you so let
me talk let me start out just by doing a
questionnaire because this is just like
I've been did a couple these sessions
that keeps happening so how many of you
have heard of the Internet great oh not
everyone well and how many of you have
seen online ads before nice nice how
many of you have clicked or bought
something often add oh yeah i was
expecting not that many hands with a
little couple so what we're trying to do
is increase that number but I improving
user engagement in serving better
content on the Internet so what is
online advertising let's say that your
business cat and your user on the
internet you really like litter boxes so
you're going to go on litter boxes calm
and just to see what's Liam you you know
the latest and greatest developments on
litter boxes so the first thing is that
the web page starts to load and there
are ad slots before the ad slots
actually populate with content in load
there are actions that are firing off
for every single one of these slots so
what's happening is that different
advertisers are bidding values into this
oxygen and they're trying to compete for
the attention of business cat so they're
going to do is just bid some value and
in this case the one of the highest is
buy one get one laser pointers and
they're trying to get business cat to
click and violate laser pointers so if
you step back there's actually millions
of auctions happening every second and
there's thousands of what of publishers
and advertisers all trying to interact
in the space so
I'm going to hand it over to sell to
explain how AppNexus fits into this
great great so AppNexus is the platform
that connects the advertisers and buyers
our technology has implemented this
auction house or at exchange where
advertisers can bid dollar amounts to
show users ads and where websites can
route all their ad traffic so that they
can monetize their inventory since it's
not a trivial technological pursuit to
participate on the ad exchange we also
offer tools for advertisers so where
they can set up their ad campaigns and
have AB Nexus do the actual bidding on
their behalf similarly we have suite of
tools for publishers to do all the sorts
of fancy analysis and revenue maximizing
for their inventory that you you know
imagine they would want so to give you
an idea of the scale at which appnexus
operates we conduct about 120 billion
plus auctions per day from those
auctions we serve 40 40 billion ads
which accounts for about 170 + terabytes
of data so to put that number in
perspective coring tool from alpha
that's enough data to fill the human
brain capacity in 12 days it's also
enough data that if you were to print it
on pieces of paper it would account for
700 billion pages of printed information
per day if you stacked all those pieces
of paper on top of each other it would
stretch 40,000 miles of printed material
which is enough to reach the moon in 6.5
days unfortunately it also costs you 273
billion dollars in printing costs so
poor big data he's always the butt of
the jokes next slide please Thanks
alright so here's a little diagram of
how we how we facilitate this at at
Nexus at a very high level so business
cat visits an ad sends the ad requests
to the app Nexus impression bus call the
impression bus because it's responsible
for routing requests to other parts of
our ad Nexus platform other subsystems
the most important of which is the app
Nexus bidder which is responsible for
taking that bid request or I'm sorry
responsible for taking that impression
the ad request and returning a bid value
which is a dollar amount and the ad
which the bitter or the advertiser is
going to display to business cat so
simultaneously the impression bus is
also routing these impression requests
to other bidders who are also returning
dollar amounts in ads so whichever
dollar amounts the highest that's which
ad gets just shown to business cat so
the app Nexus bidder besides for
returning an add request also wats a
piece of information about the auction
and about the bids into HDFS which is
our urban file system which contains all
the raw log data on the ad next platform
from there it's processed by our data
pipeline which does basically
aggregations to store it in a consumable
format for different processes on the at
Nexus platform we use a vertical
database mostly to store this aggregated
information and then the data science
and optimization portion of at Nexus
this is where we fit in here so we
consume from the vertical database do a
bunch of different calculations on the
aggregated data for a bunch of different
purposes talk about one purpose today
but we do a ton of computation and store
the results of this computation into my
sequel database where it's been written
by the at mix is better to influence
future bids so this is the feedback loop
over here as far as the optimization
data science teams are concerned the
majority of what we do but not all of it
but the majority is all offline learning
offline computation which really lets us
take advantage of high-level programming
languages like Python and lets us sort
of ignore the problems of you know how
do we how exactly can we read in and
process billions of requests a second we
can sort of like not worry about that
and really worried about just
implementing the business logic to
iterate fast great so today we're going
to talk about a very specific problem of
the dais and op data science and
optimization teams so we're going to
zoom in zoom in a little more into
performance buying performance buying is
a very specific type of trade
action that happens on the app Nexus
exchange it's when a website will only
get paid if a user engages with an ad
for example a user clicks on an ad or
user makes a purchase base often it of
an ad and so on the flip side the
advertiser will only pay out when this
action occurs so here's a little example
where Bobo a laser pointer says to
litter boxes com I'll give you ten
dollars if somebody clicks on my ad
litter boxes com only sees that offers
only sees that offer so he says sure why
not but once we introduce different
advertisers into the ecosystem things
become a little more complicated you
have all these offers which the
advertisers are pitching to litter boxes
com for example hundred dollars for a
purchase or I'll give you seven dollars
per click so it's it's not as simple as
choosing the highest dollar amount
because as you can imagine not all these
offers are created equal the probability
of purchasing a car based on an ad may
not be as likely as clicking on you want
a free iPad maybe it is I don't know so
in a very ideal world where at Nexus is
omniscient being we would know exactly
which of these offers events happens so
we know exactly when a user would
purchase an event based on an ad
unfortunately we don't we're not this
all-knowing being so we can't do that
the next best case scenario is if we
knew the probability for which an event
happened if we knew the probability for
example that a click that a click
happened and we and we knew the
probability was ten percent and we knew
that the value the offer amount for that
click was ten dollars we could do a
simple calculation to calculate the
expected value of the viewer or
impression by saying $10 times ten
percent is a dollar and if a dollar is
the highest offer amount or the highest
translated offer amounts then we would
choose that offer to display to the
publisher or the website so this makes
sense when we have enough data to do
this computation we just get the number
of clicks divided by the number of
impressions for some offer website
combination unfortunately it becomes a
much more difficult problem when we
don't have any data and we can't make
this computation so Stephanie is going
to talk
you about what we do in the situation
Stephanie thanks so so nice all right so
before I actually talked about having
data ornate no data I'm going to talk a
little bit about just how important is
to have that one rare event so in this
case we're talking about a click the
probability of click as said before is
really important for us to know what the
expected value of that offers so if you
look at if you have no clicks but you
have some other data because we're
dealing with probabilities here it just
doesn't tell us anything so 0 10
impressions or 0 out ten thousand
impressions there's 0 is the same thing
as zero but if you get one click then
you're actually getting some kind of
probability we're getting somewhere so
let me delve a little bit more into the
data and no data problem if you can
think of this as a classic exploit and
explore problem if you have data we call
this an optimized state that's when you
have a real probability you're pretty
confident in it and the purpose of this
is to go out and just get revenue for
the publisher or the website the other
state is the learn state that's the
exploration state we don't have any
probability or we just don't have that
much data and so in this case we're
actually buying impressions to
accumulate information so the seller our
website can say like ninety-five percent
of impressions are going to optimize
whereas the five percent is going to
learn so how do we estimate this initial
probability for no data so in the old
scheme what we did was we computed some
kind of prediction for every single
offer and website combination and we
would update the model as we started to
get data the problem is that we're
storing all of this in memory so every
single combination that's just a lot of
information and the other problem is
that elaborate probability prediction
schemes are actually not necessarily
that accurate and you end up collecting
data like all these impressions for
every single offer so you're slowly
getting impressions but not necessarily
the clicks
so let me dive a little bit in detail
for what might happen for one website so
in our bitter memory restoring
valuations for all the offers so it
doesn't really make sense that we're
still storing it for Justin Bieber fanny
packs when it's like this slow and so
all this this ellipses obviously mean
there's stuff in the middle so why do we
continue doing this so the solution is
what we call the quick test approach and
in this case is for offers but you can
actually extend the same algorithm four
different use cases so our hypothesis is
that for information gathering it is
more cost effective to test out what we
call enough impressions for a
concentrated number of offers then
buying impressions for every single
offer based off of a flawed prediction
so as you recall the click is the most
important thing it has holds the key to
most of your information so we're going
to use that click as a classifier so if
you have a click we're going to say
that's good if it's up there's no click
then that's bad okay so what's enough
impressions um we go into a little bit
of math here n impressions is the
minimal amount of impressions you need
to deem that an offer is bad even though
no clicks have happened so first thing
you do is you calculate a desired
probability so P naught is equal to this
equation that uses an average revenue
for the seller and a goal which is in
our previous example is ten dollars per
click so now you have a baseline then
there's an actual p value which is your
actual click-through rate for the offer
and website so what you do is you
calculate based off of this equation
here so I'm going to step through this
it's the probability that the real
conversion rate is greater than P naught
that means the offer is good given that
no clicks have happened and any
impressions heavy laps you set that
lesser than equal to this lambda factor
which is a false positive rate and I'm
going to go into more detail about that
so so this is a conditional probability
so clearly we use Bayes theorem you
rewrite it like this and then we can
finally rewrite it in this format here
this is based theorem and 1 minus P to
the N is using the binomial distribution
because every single impression either
goes to a click or no click and since
there have been no events of success
it's um your probability of failures to
the nth power and you pick some kind of
underlying distribution for your prior
which is H of P and you can compute n
with this all right so you might be
wondering what lambda means so the
relationship between lambda and n is
this if you have not that many
impressions you aren't very sure what
that means it could mean that the offer
is good so your your false negative rate
is really high if you want to lower your
false negative rate you can just
continue to increase the number of
impressions that you're you're testing
but doesn't really make sense to test
like infinite impressions because then
you're just you're just wasting a lot of
money but that could mean that you have
no false negatives so what you end up
doing is you pick some kind of low false
negative rate and then you can solve
this equation for n and then you stopped
buying there okay now let's talk about
pregnancy tests so if you are taking a
pregnancy test you want to see false
positives re you want to see true
positives but you don't want to see
false positives so the same way here
that's what I'm ROC curve kind is so
what you want to see is what the ideal
places in ideally for pregnancy test you
want to be right here so what you do in
this situation is you look at your data
you try out all these different lambda
values so you're trying to be as close
as possible I deal with we aren't really
there but you just want to pick
someplace on this curve and if you're
over here you're probably wasting a lot
of impressions so you just have to it's
kind of like your own use case whatever
you think is most appropriate for you so
here's just a state diagram of what the
offer looks like first it goes into an
eligible state then it starts testing it
tests for n impressions and if it gets a
click it passes if it doesn't it fails
okay so know me well let me talk about
the implementation of this there are
three steps the first is a rink so what
you do is based off of your predicted
revenue this is a little bit like doing
the probability prediction but it's more
lenient towards being not as accurate
like you don't have to be as accurate
here so you rank your offers based off
of historical information in some kind
of prediction the second step is you
select a top number of offers so this is
the a pretty important part because the
hypothesis was saying don't look at
everything only look at a small amount
of offers at a time so you can test it
fully so in this case what you do is you
look at the average number of
impressions that was elapsed over like
let's say seven days and if you want the
offers to test in a day you can use this
fancy thing called the vision and you
can figure out the number of offers all
right the last step is the quick test
which I already went over so this is
still the same number of offers that we
were talking about earlier so during
those n impressions per offer then if it
if it passes it goes into the optimized
state and if it fails they go to sin to
this horrible place called at Hill isn't
actually this so let me go into a little
bit of the results as I said before
there's too much information in memory
right now so we wanted to reduce the
number of objects testing at a time and
also by doing that you're a lot
efficient so this purple line here is
when we turned on the algorithm and then
you see the number of objects testing at
a time has decreased dramatically in the
next slide just shows that the blue line
is the average number average revenue
per thousand impressions and after we
turn on the feature we started to see a
lot of better results now we will talk
about the engineering part of this all
right thanks Stephanie it's time to put
the PI and PI data all right I'm done
talks over just kidding all right so if
you recall this is the state diagram
this is the implementation of offer
quick test as we sort of see it on the
engineering side we want these offers to
go into sort of a start off in an
eligible state then go into a testing
state where there later either put into
a passed or failed state so this by
itself doesn't seem like a terribly
challenging problem but what makes it
complicated is the scale at which we at
which we do this so we're talking about
websites or we're talking about offers
serving on websites and as you can
imagine there are tons of offers tons of
advertisers with tons of offers and tons
of websites on which these offers can
serve so if you have such a large
combination of things then it becomes
much more difficult to do this state
transition this is a diagram of the
system the architecture that supports
offer quick test and as you can see it's
a little bit involved there are a lot of
moving parts and the reason for that is
because the scale at which were
operating there's not a single process
or it would be infeasible for a single
process to ingest the data that we need
to process do all the processing itself
and spit out the testing offers or
transitioned offers or past offers and
failed offers so we need to have some
way of splitting up the computation
splitting up the tasks into logical
steps and this diagram kind of outlines
what's going on
although I won't dive into exactly the
specifics of this these the stopper over
here all the cylinders you see our data
stores these arrows represent flows of
data rectangle things the small
rectangles are Python processes that are
used to do a variety of computation
Python processes you can see the data
flowing to other data stores to other
Python processes this box here it's hard
to see but eventually the final step of
all the computation that we do is our
bitter mechanism which takes in the new
offers that are testing on a website or
the new offers that have failed on a
website or pass on the website and makes
bids accordingly all right a guest
celebrity appearance all right so how do
we facilitate all this computation whoo
all right subscribe how do we facilitate
all this computation so you saw from the
last slide that there are a lot of
moving parts a lot of things that need
to be coordinated a lot of Python
processes specifically that need to be
coordinated so to do this at Nexus we've
implemented distributed work you and if
you're unfamiliar with distributed work
use its as the name suggests a way to
distribute computation across different
machines and the necessary component in
your system if you're doing lots of
computation on lots of data so for our
purposes we're going to call a large
unit of work a job we're going to say
that jobs are small are split into
smaller units of work call tasks it's a
job of a scheduler to kick off a job and
chard it into many tasks for computation
on worker machines so on the
optimization team we've implemented our
own in-house distributed work queue it
uses RabbitMQ to facilitate message
passing between workers and schedulers
in between external sources external
sources and our scheduler to kick off
any sorts of computations that we want
to do so it's very similar to celery
which is another distributed task thing
built in python that you might be
familiar with our scheduler begins a job
when it
sees a notification on the rabid
exchange besides for spinning off tasks
to do the computation it also sort of
state information in my sequel so we
always have a global view of exactly
what is running and a history of what's
run and when so here's an example of how
it fits together so if you recall the
data pipeline is the part of the larger
data flow where our data is aggregated
from its raw raw log data form into a
more consumable format so once the data
pipeline is done with a specific
aggregation it will send a message to
the RabbitMQ exchange which then routes
the message to our scheduler the
scheduler looks at the data source which
has been aggregated decides whether
there are any important jobs or any jobs
that's the optimization team is
interested in that does computation
based on this data if so it'll take it
will spawn off a job split it into tasks
send those tasks right back over to
RabbitMQ where there's distributed
across several workers and the workers
do the number crunching they do the
computation and then store the output
into some other data source so in the
case of our offers in the case of our
transitioning offers this might be the
my sequel database from which are bitter
reads so the my sequel database where we
store the offer States it also could be
some intermediate intermediate cash
layer and it often is as we'll talk
about later so yeah that's the work of
that's the work of the workers I put a
little doges there because each of the
workers runs a watchdog process but it's
much more fun say watch Doge sort of
watchdog great so rabbitmq why why do we
use RabbitMQ and how is it helpful for
implementing a distributor work you so
for our purposes these might vary but
for our purposes is a dab Nexus on the
optimization team we're not interested
in really pushing any messaging broker
system to the limit we're really only
sending tens of messages per second over
the rabbit exchange not millions of
messages per second although it does
support that the thing that we are
interested in and the thing that's
important to us is having flexibility
the power to create semi complicated
rules when when sending messages over
the exchange semi complicated mean
meaning some messages should be destined
for workers other for schedulers some
messages should have some priorities
some messages should only or some
consumers should only listen to some
format of some messages and really
rabbit has a lot of flexibility with
regarding with regard to routing rules
that makes it a nice solid choice for
distributed work you like this the other
important thing that rabbits there's a
very good job of its fault tolerance so
it's unacceptable for us to have message
failure or any draft messages anything
like that because it's results in jobs
not running or tasks not running which
results in stale or incorrect data so
for example if we have an offer on a
website that isn't a testing stage but
it should be failed it's it's taking the
impressions it's taking user views that
should be allocated to other offers so
wasting impressions wasting money for a
publisher also we use pica which is a
package used to communicate with rabbit
exchange has fantastic support Python
package they're a bunch of other
features that make rabbit pretty ideal
for the sort of setup great so now we
have an idea of how we carry out
computations how we coordinate
computations so let's talk a little bit
more about the data flow a little more
in depth so this is the data flow a
little more in depth like I was saying
we start off with all our data in HDFS
where it's later aggregated and stored
into vertica this green box represents
all the sort of the optimization stack
where all of our Python processes are
running and crunching and crunching
numbers the two main components that
make up the stack are the caching of
data from our vertical cluster into
Redis we'll go into the specifics later
but this is a this is a very important
process for us
there are many processes that are
reading or that are using the data that
we've aggregated in different and
interesting ways and it's very
inefficient to be hitting our vertical
cluster every single time so we have
lots of helper modules that pull off the
data parse it in and kind of put into
formats that are more useful for the
final stage of this process process
which is the transitioning of offers
from eligible to testing to pasture
failed from there we store store the
results into my sequel and as I was
saying sync it over to bitter memory and
now the bitter knows what should be
testing what are the good offers what
are the bad offers which ads should i
should i be serving so HDFS do
distributed file system I'm sure you're
all familiar this is this is what really
counts for the hundred plus terabytes of
data a day this is where it all begins
so HDFS is amazing for very large data
sets its fault tolerant which is super
important for us and and our particular
cluster is composed of fourteen hundred
machines across two data centers one in
New York in one in LA so you are here
the data is now in HDFS so first step is
to aggregate it so i talked about
vertica or i mentioned Vertica vertica
is an HP product it's a column store
database which means it's very good at
performing fast irrigations across
columns verdict is also horizontally
scaling which is one of the big reasons
we use it at nexus we experimented
earlier in the early in the early
history of at mexis with other databases
for the use case of storing this
aggregated form of raw data and found
that a lot of different solutions didn't
really scale with what or scale as well
as we needed it to so vertical supports
freaking querying and our vertical
clusters composed about 150 vertical
nodes all the aggregations are done in
Java and they're supported by the app
Nexus data team
just build a giant infrastructure around
pumping data from Hadoop into vertica in
meaningful ways and using complex logic
so we make pretty heavy use of that so
the particular table that stores all the
information that we are interested in
for the transitioning of offers on
websites this is the schema for it as of
last check it was about 332 billion rows
of data which is non-trivial it has the
information that you would expect which
is impression the compression count so
how many views have happened on an offer
website combination how many clicks have
happened and how many conversions
purchases for example have happened on
this combination these are the keys to
our offer website combinations we go a
little bit more granular into sort of
what is what is an offer for example and
what is a website for example but
essentially they just basically tell
that story and these these are the
historical stats on those combinations
great so we're here now we're dancin
vertica aggregated in a neat way it's
time to run our army of Python processes
that reading this data do some crunching
do some manipulation and then hash it so
cash money all right so yeah as I was
saying there's there's lots of processes
that need to access the same aggregated
data and it would be terribly
inefficient if all of them had to queer
Vertica constantly and like you saw
there's sort of this big synchronization
sort of thing that we have to do on the
optimization team so it's it's honestly
just very useful to have an intermediate
caching layer where all these processes
where all the relevant processes can
sort of ping and access instead of going
to kind of the main source so how do we
do it how do we or what do we use to go
from vertica aggregated data store into
a caching layer so we make pretty heavy
use of pandas
the outsides ation team and pan is sure
you all are familiar as well has great
support for representing rows and
columns in memory via the data frames
class so the API supports really complex
row manipulations and for the most part
we can let pandas worry about
performance for the most part which is
nice and so how we use it is we sort of
read it all into memory or in each of
our sort of sharted tasks we read we
read all this data into memory do some
Roman dip ulation and then kind of right
off the results somewhere else under the
hood we use standard peyote bc and io
pro if you're unfamiliar with io pro
it's a continuum product whose sponsor
also sponsor here at pi data and just
makes memory performance much better for
panda state of frames or just panis
objects in general when storing
information from external data sources
so you're just a snippet of code you can
see we create a setup of vertical
connection and we've built kind of our
own API select data frame so we do make
heavy use of pandas so examples of
things that we cash so i told you that
it's important to cash because because
there are lots of different processes
accessing lots of different data in
different ways so examples of the things
that we that we cache or websites with
new data we don't want to transition
offers on websites that don't have you
data because there would really be no
need to if they don't have any if it
offers testing on website there's no
need to do any sort of transitioning or
it would be pointless to to continue
with any transitioning because it
doesn't have data another important
thing is how many offers should be
testing on each website at a time this
is hugely important for our transition
er process because it needs to know you
know if there's if an offers failed for
example how many offers should take its
place you know could be could be one or
perhaps the volume on a website has gone
up tenfold since the last time this
algorithm ran and a website with a
billion impressions per day would
obviously need or
maybe more offers testing on it then you
know Sal's blog com which has maybe 10
pressions per day we also want to know
which offers are allowed to serve on
which countries or which sizes because
you know not all all ads can serve on
all countries or ad sizes we also want
to know how many impressions clicks or
conversions have happened on a website
offer combination this is the vital sort
of information that we need or that our
transition er needs because as stephanie
was explaining after n impressions after
a certain number of impressions if you
haven't got to click on an offer we
consider the offer bad and we scrap it
and put it into failed state so what do
we use for caching well we use Redis
sure if you're unfamiliar is a key value
store in memory the reason we chose
write us at Nexus is because it has a
very rich feature set it has sets hash
sets ordered sets all of which we use in
our implementation of this transitioning
process the thing that Redis doesn't
have were maybe one of the complicating
factors complicating factors of Redis is
that it is just a key value store in
that for the most part you're putting in
strings you're pulling out strings
there's nothing really else going on
there so that on the optimization team
we've sort of built an intermediate
layer that that sort of puts a model
abstraction on top of on top of Redis
which lets us enforce best practices
like serialization do serialization
define namespaces and lets us treat our
our interaction with ritis like as if or
it lets us retrieve information from
Metis as if their native Python objects
just bring unique we use right as PI API
another Python package has been really
great Obi where resource starvation so
this process of pulling from vertica and
caching you know we're really really
hitting vertica kind of constantly in
order to retrieve the most up-to-date
data can really put a strain on our
vertical clusters and vertica has a
interesting way of dealing with resource
management and that it allocates a big
chunk of resources for every query
that's that's running on the vertical
cluster so we noticed that in the
process of
you know creating vertica so frequently
we'd often find that a lot of our
creatives would fail because of resource
resource starvation so to prevent that
we use apache zookeeper which is a
service that provides distributed
synchronization for systems like this
and it was really helpful for sort of
mitigating these resource starvation
problems that we had and we use
concealer with kazoo which is a Python
package used to interact with patching
zookeeper please help I'm so hungry says
the resource next slide please alright
you're here redis so the all the day is
in Redis so now it's finally time for
our you know transition er to run data
is in a nice form consumable formats so
all that's left is really to transition
into my sequel so do the final
computations of course this is also
distributed across our across many
machines but now the process is much
simpler because our data is in a ready
state so now we can take offers we know
exactly how many impressions they get
they got how many clicks they've got so
we can put them into the appropriate
states save these states into my sequel
and we do that we also use sequel
alchemy which I'm sure all of you are
familiar with to do a lot of the rights
to my sequel here's just an example some
familiar sequel alchemy syntax using
sessions and whatnot but data is in my
sequel now we can perform the sink to
bitter memory and kind of complete this
feedback loop so bitter reason my sequel
now makes bids according to the offers
and the states that those offers are in
great so moral of this there's actually
not really immoral but we needed a nice
transition slide to the Thank You slide
so it is scale codes and math on really
the big picture and sort of the thing
that's a lot of you are probably dealing
with for whatever you're doing and the
thing that Maxis deals with on a daily
basis is sort of how how scale
influences the math and the codes of our
systems so this is sort of the Holy
Church
idiots it's the it's combining scale
it's combining codons combining math and
kind of this beautiful and optimal form
to support things that you know we're
not possible kind of before but anyway
these are the sort of problems that
you're interested in we're hiring as
always and thank you yeah yeah it
depends on the particular job that we're
running for the transitioning of offers
for the for the algorithm that we just
discussed it's twice an hour so every 30
minutes about yeah but it yeah it
depends it depends on exactly what we're
running cuz a bunch of jobs have
different frequencies some are more
critical than others but yeah
yes yes yeah the questions concerns go
ahead sure sure
yes so I mean we do we do so all that I
kind of put a cloud where that happened
which is the data pipeline which does a
bunch of really interesting things but
that is one of the things that it does
another really cool thing that we that
we support now at Nexus and is sort of
the direction that we're going down is
not only do we take this data and kind
of pump it into an aggregated form in a
vertical database we also allow any
application to read from the stream of
data in real time so that they can
perform online learning or use it for
online learning applications there's a
couple of data scientists in the crowd
today but have some experience with that
if you're interested but j-money and Sam
shout out yeah
oh so it's not on a user combination so
it's a just website well so it's not
actually just website it's like a very
granular number like a abstraction of
inventory and also a lot of different
objects for live by side but we're
accumulating impressions overtime just
to test out that offer not necessarily
for a particular user though so it's
like a a particular website might happen
to have more better performance for
particular advertiser and so we have to
slice it that way for the two
combinations
so that's like an another part another
layer to this it is part of our
advertising technology but I didn't
really talk about it here this this
particular algorithm doesn't address it
but we have another like this actual
algorithm can be used to address that
boo by testing out users but I mean it's
just like one example of using it yep
okay so um I can go back a lot of slides
for that okay so you choose a prior um
and we just chose something that kind of
mimics what a probability distribution
for clicks is so if you take something
that like a rare event but it basically
shows that there are very rare events
you could just do that and oh my gosh
there's so many slides inside okay
celebrity I wonder if I could have just
like minimize the slide and oh we're
almost there oh well wow there's so many
slides okay here we go um so is this the
question that you had this one basically
the prior you can choose whatever you
want here so you can even take like a
uniform distribution it's not what we
did and then right here this is just
like we use the probability 0 so we
integrate from the desired probability
to a one and then we just um you update
the model using that so what your
question was like what what's fires
this one all that that equation is just
a rewriting of this one because you're
saying what's the probability of Pete
your actual conversion rate which you
don't know give in 0 and n is the number
that you're trying to change over time
so you're you're just solving for that
equation and P is something that changes
because you're integrating from that
first initial probability to 1 so that's
just a variable yep yeah I use a beta
distribution I was like I think we use
the Jefferies prior good
let's just do this no okay no no problem
so it was a the resource starvation
problem was rooted in sort of a
synchronization problem which is that we
would often find a lot of processes just
querying vertica at the same time yes
yeah sure so it's actually Apache
zookeeper that just allows us to have a
synchronization mechanism that's that
supports our sort of distributed system
because there's no way for these
processes to interact with each other or
I mean there are but the way that they
sort of like tell each other who should
be accessing Vertica or who shouldn't be
accessing vertigo who should be waiting
for Vertica access is through Apache
zookeeper so do keep your dusting kryn
ization exactly yeah thank you okay
alright thanks guys come talk to us
about jobs